Sharon Stone turning heads in a sexy  green mini dress on the red carpet for  her new romantic comedy a little  something for your birthday  her son stepping in as her dates for the  big event so you have your three boys  did you ever give them dating advice  game over I will not let her because  he's six now he's 16 and he's too young  do I give you good advice fifty  nine-year-old Sharon seem to share the  same sentiments as her boys about her  own mom's advice my mother did not give  me any good advice about dating the best  advice she gave me was to put a dime in  my shoe because I never know when I  might need to make a phone call the  single actress says she's looking for  love I'm hoping that romance will one  day it'd be funny if romance came into  my life  [Music]  you  [Music]